just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
you know if you go out and you want to
buy groceries you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his
own doral golf club take care of the
floors you know the floors of the forest
it's very important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red from suchin
kendo kerr to virot colleen
trump tweeting the new york times they
are a
true enemy of the people i think we have
enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go this russian
bounty story
we have multiple sources saying that
trump knew all along i was there for a
tiny
little short period of time it was much
more for an inspection there was no
problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're gonna have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay
rare trump ordered robert mueller
the special prosecutor be fired the
factory policy is
wear a mask at all times and trump puts
on goggles but no mask
and we're building a wall in colorado
we're building a beautiful wall trump
floated the idea
of swapping puerto rico for greenland
the ram that i descended after my west
point commencement speech was very long
and steep
had no handrail and most importantly was
very slippery
our army manned the air it ran
the ramparts it took over the airports
it did everything it had to do
wherever trump goes he tries to make
himself seem dominant over whoever he's
shaking hands with trump's
strong-looking situation room photo was
a staged photograph
likely taken hours after the event lock
them up you should lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary i
too have a nuclear button
but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his
the narcissist in chief donald trump
wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks
he's not reading a presidential daily
briefing
that has been dumbed down to one page
mostly pictures graphs and maps get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now out he's fired
he's fired so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail
the wind direction shifted and it sort
of split his hair
sort of back to front trump was laughed
at
by the entire room of world leaders at
the united nations one of the wettest
we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water and then
they did dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps
lavar ball
is unaccepting of what i did for his son
i should have left them
in jail these aren't people
these are animals the same vaccine could
not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
no cummings district is a disgusting rat
and rodent
infested mess
compared to other presidents trump has
golfed more
than any modern president cnn should be
ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude
terrible person trump showed up and
started throwing
paper towels to people like he was
shooting free throws
in basketball donald trump's decision to
do the corona caravan drive
around walter reed well it's not the
hardest task no but
you see that's all misrepresentation
well that's what the white house had put
together a statement
praising mccain and his life and his
heroism trump said no no statement i'll
post a tweet
instead this is the guy who stared
directly
at a solar eclipse i wanted to always
play it down
i still like playing it down trump
shared a video
of a supporter of his yelling white
power moment of the sexual experience
would ask the young lady who's your
daddy this should be remixed if officer
akeemov
is watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer
akimov is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
[Music]
manning
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth
to reverence the word of god to trust it
to preach it
to teach it loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
bush and george bush jr have been
penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
oh i got down on my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted sounds
like quite an evening
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it with semen that
certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
each other's semen how do you know that
it flavors the coffee gays tend to love
each other's semen
[Music]
each other's semen how do you know that
it flavors the coffee
gays tend to love each other's semen
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
all right welcome everybody that's the
latest uh hit record
from office akimov not officer akimov
office akimov and always welcome
uh more submissions from uh the office
yeah okay very good we're here for
something that
you know my prediction is this is not a
stream that's going to do particularly
well why because it's actually
substantive
yeah it's depressing joe biden is going
to be holding a joint press conference
with the german chancellor dr
angela merkel not a medical doctor by
the way
many people will make that very very
clear um
and they will be normalizing diplomatic
relations and will probably relate to
each other
in a sort of normal way and that's
important that's a change from what we
had previously
and um that is coming up in about 20
minutes so we're standing by for that
and i have a lot of things to get to
between now and then
um and in fact emmanuel kant
jumping in with the first super chat
today says long live the transatlantic
relationship love from germany
with a five euro super chat five euro
must be worth what like a thousand us
dollars at this point
who even knows where that exchange rate
is i do want to say thank you to sienna
bork
sienna or burke sienna burke bork
sienna is new member number one today at
joinpackman.com and i also want to say
thanks to micro kimmy
as well as hack foue for the early
twitch prime subs putting us at three
it would be delightful to be forced to
open the phone lines today and i will do
that if we get to 100 website members
and twitch subscribers
but there is so much to get to between
now and then where to even start
um actually i don't even know where to
start hold on i had my notes here
um oh okay i do i was sent
a few new elements that i want to play
for you guys
uh first of all i have increased now
my joe biden audio elements to seven
and we now have the following and by the
way maybe you could inject some bleach
in your arm and that would take care of
it
okay come on man give me a break
with all due respect that's a bunch of
malarkey that's a bunch of malarkey
this idea is a bunch of malarkey well
you should
listen okay so we've we've got seven
biden elements now i am now up to six
bernard sanders elements i wrote the
damn bill
i do know and i wrote the day of bill i
wrote the day of bill
your damn emails you're wrong
yeah good okay all right so those are
the bernie elements
i have one new song this is a
um a dumps remix of take on me
i think it stops too early that's my
critique of it
and then they did dumps they call them
dumps big massive dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
yeah my critique is it ends too soon i
would like to go into the next verse i
think that would make it a little bit
better
and then lastly so i have so many trump
clips at this point that i've had to
turn them into subfolders which makes it
a little hard to manage but i have
a couple of new uh classics now very
much available
cephei exactly
we've got looking at that very strongly
we've got that
then he went donald trump yeah donald
trump there's the infamous prompt
it's not racist at all no no exactly one
of the wettest we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water throwing
the hell out of here
fresh vegetables that's my fresh
vegetables
fresh vegetables okay so we've got that
and
then i also have a bunch i have a covid
subsection as well
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
uh by injection inside or
oh no my plasma ones are still not
working we hit the body
with a tremendous uh very powerful light
apply light and heat to supposedly
the light inside the body
yeah most of my plasma ones are invalid
i don't know why
um okay but that so so you know we're
continuing to build
i think that's all i've got yep that's
all i've got for now
all right so that we're up to date on
update on the
pacman live youtube channel we are now
getting
very very close to our first 10 000
subscribers on pacman live
this started very very recently i think
we're only like a few weeks in
five weeks in four weeks in something
like that uh youtube.com
pacmanlive and we are i'm we're still
pushing for our first 10
000 subscribers here these are
highlights from the streams our regular
youtube channel is so
full or full as some say that
the clips from the streams go on this
other channel and there's a lot of good
stuff on it and we're starting to get
some clips that will get
you know 10 20 even 30 000 uh views
and that's really exciting that's
youtube.com pacman live 10 people just
dropped in
out of nowhere so that's the update on
pacman live
um let me see what else i had from this
standpoint i think that's my latest
update
on that as we stand by for joe biden
let's read a few super chats
jonathan brown says cnn had george bush
on expressing his concern for the afghan
people with biden pulling troops out
can you imagine anything more
hypocritical yeah i've talked about this
a lot
you know at a certain point i get that
we broke it there's no doubt there's no
doubt we broke it by going in
and that gives us a responsibility to
some degree to stay
to fix it but it's almost like we're
making we're not it's not going to get
fixed for as long as we're there so at
some point i do think that it becomes a
moral imperative to simply say
we can't we did break it but at some
point we're not ever going to fix it so
we've got to get out
that's that's my perspective at this
point big boo boo says david did you see
the
copa america argentina won
i had no idea sir i didn't know that
that happened of course
of course i watched every game huge huge
win for argentina incredible
bay photo says i think trump's comments
on millie show he's attempt a coup
all over again without question yeah we
covered the milly trump stuff on today's
podcast
klaus a lot of germans coming out of
note coming out of the woodwork
materializing spontaneously because of
today's event
klaus says meeting greetings from
germany a new parliament and thus
chancellor is up for election in
september
merkel isn't running a very mixed bag
outlook yeah we'll we'll talk about that
as we close in on september
um you may so we're going to have a real
contrast in diplomacy today
we learned uh yesterday due to excerpts
from the new book
um oh god what what oh i alone can fix
it the book i alone can fix it revealed
that donald trump reportedly called
merkel a [ __ ]
in the oval office as well as a crowd
that's trump diplomacy with germany
today we're going to see joe biden and
angela merkel
uh hold the joint press conference my
senses the dynamics will be very very
different
but that's a great uh great to hear from
our german friends
i do want to say thank you to
julian cianciolo who is
the latest website member using the
coupon code
sad trump which makes you new member
number four today
and i very much appreciate that also
thank you to pr smoker
sue me long and asf clops
for the twitch prime subscriptions
number five six
and seven make sure you're using those
bezos bucks i do plan to cover
actually does anyone i want to cover the
bezos space launch on the 20th
does anybody know what time it's
happening because
i'm going to need to maybe uh rearrange
my day on the 20th but i would love to
cover that live
anybody have any idea when is the bezos
launch
i mean listen if you want bezos to keep
your bezos bucks then by all means don't
sign up for twitch prime but
um let's see jeff bezos july 20
launch time 9 a.m
okay all right well i'm willing to do
that it'll be an early stream that i'll
probably start at 8 45.
i'll have to change around man maybe i
should even
look at uh filming
the podcast the day before or something
like that we'll see
we'll see but i do want to check that
out um
maximum punk says can you add explosive
trees to the audio clips that's not a
bad one i don't know if it's a top trump
clip
but it's not bad it's not bad okay i did
get this
this was sent to me this is someone
trolling pretending to be a conservative
trolling a school board meeting on the
topic of critical race theory i really
like this check this out
i'm here to say that we need to end
forced indoctrination
in our schools and right after we do
that we
need to whenever we end the fourth
indoctrination
we need to mandate that everyone stands
for the pledge of allegiance
direct your comments to the board i just
want to say you know just
you know as a conservative just because
i don't know anything about critical
race theory it doesn't mean i
can't talk about critical races
i have no idea on the background of this
but i'm loving it
this guy right here i don't know if this
guy's liking it or not it's like
you know
okay so then they shut them down that's
really nicely done really really nicely
done i i um that's that's good stuff
um okay good so we got that
just going through my other items here
jeffrey says david on the second channel
will you upload the live stream of you
laughing at the rudy giuliani hair dye
meltdown
okay if someone in the audience can go
back to that stream we now have a live
a past live stream shelf on the main
channel
if you can get us some time codes of
that entire fiasco and my out of control
laughing from the
hair dye thing we will we'll we'll clip
that and we'll put it on the new channel
i think that's a really really nice idea
actually
but we do need a little bit of help with
that and uh yeah another 10 subscribers
dropping in on pacman live we will we
will put we will get that put up and
quick
and quick uh because that is that's a
good that's a good segment
that would be great okay excellent next
i've been asked to react to this video
okay my understanding i have there's
apparently
a growing debate if you can imagine over
the term
gusano which in a literal sense means
worm
but my view is it's often
sort of used to refer to white latin
americans
as a pejorative this is apparently
hassan [ __ ] saying it's fine
to use the term and then stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
saying it's not okay to use it so i've
not yet seen this it's a one-minute clip
let's take a listen and see where i come
down on it uh
uh people uh want to make it uh out to
be a
want to make it out to be a [ __ ] like
slur or something it just means worm
okay
it's a this take here and i understand
that we're doing frat boy politics now
so i don't expect them to say anything
you know intelligent right but the like
it just means
worm like negro is just
black and spanish or like wet back is
just it means that you have a sweaty
back like
how stupid do you have to be to say
something like this like
how many racial slurs how many slur
words are literally just um are
literally just like words for something
else
like how how stupid do you have to be to
say something like this
like like how many racial stories just
mean something or like the f slur
just means like a bundle of sticks like
yeah i agree uh 110 with stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
um he's completely right now
i don't i don't use any of these words i
find them all
completely unproductive from the
standpoint of actually discussing
policy but um there's no
like by the way it's funny sometimes
when i'm like hey you know
um the the cuban embargo is really bad
that the uh the u.s should stop the
cuban embargo
and the u.s should not in any way
intervene in cuba
and as a progressive i can't possibly
defend
an authoritarian castro regime that took
power in 1959
lasted 49 years at which point
fidel turned over power to his brother
i'm a progressive so that's not
something i'm going to be praising
and then oh david you're a gusano
because your family
was the rich argentinian whites who fled
and had the money to flee
when [ __ ] got bad and it's like whoa
hold on a second guys let's see if we
can back up about 10 steps
my family left argentina because we had
no money
my dad was a doctor in argentina but
when he came to the u.s
he was no longer a licensed doctor and
his first job
he made 29 000 a year right
uh so no no no like it's all like
there's nothing even
remotely material there but i do think
that
the term gusano is overwhelmingly
racially uh used for white latin
americans now what's funny is the
neo-nazis and the white supremacists say
i'm not white
so you know we can talk about my my so
societally assigned race
it's all it's all bs and so yeah i agree
with stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
on this issue um it's not a good term
it's not a good look to use it
um it it it is uh in practice you know
and this this debate over is it a slur
you know it's it's disproportion it's
sort of like calling people
karen's which i don't do it's being
disproportionately applied to white
people and so therefore
it's not super progressive from my
perspective to use it
uh all right clip that guys if you want
that seems like it would be something uh
yeah i mean come on guys come on this uh
i'm not an authoritarian okay
all right so that is that i'm not saying
karen is the same
i'm not saying and none of these things
are the same
but i try to to stay away from uh any of
these racialized
terms okay a big big thank you
to oh no i already thanked julian all
right good
okay everything's good all right let's
get to some other
let's let's keep going through some
voicemails we've been working through
the voicemails i've been going through a
few
um a few each each stream let's just
dive in in order
hi there uh my name's kaylee i live in
canada big fan of your show
um i really enjoyed your segment with
co-founder of healthy gamer
and have two questions uh number one do
you practice mindfulness and meditation
i do and if so have you found it useful
yes i have number two do you think
mindfulness education on a larger scale
would help in the deprogramming of those
who have been misinformed as the
realities of u.s politics
climate change and science in general
yeah i think to some degree it would
i think to some degree it would yeah um
for sure
for sure hey david mike from new york
uh but the fall of the last election and
the attempted coup
back in january has made my brother
basically lose hope in
our democracy he firmly believes that if
the republicans
take back the house and the senate uh
that there's no chance the democrat will
ever be president ever again
especially in 2024 he thinks that they
will simply reject
any results that
well that isn't beneficial to them and
just because they think they have the
authority to do so and they're just
going to completely disregard the
constitution
of course they are and we need to move
ahead without i mean yeah that's not
really a consideration particularly at
this point in time for me
cameron mccabe says did i get the email
about the crowder joke i did but it
didn't link to a specific time code
uh for whatever reason when i opened it
it goes direct to spotify and there's no
time code link so i didn't uh
it it was not i wasn't able to find it
from that standpoint i guess is what i'm
trying to say
okay let's um let's keep going
so i liked about them i said that
aaron's had like a few inventions
but it's like how do i know that they
even invented that how do i know that
like they didn't just use slaves and
stuff and then take the credit for it
the only thing did the arabs not really
invent stuff and
instead it was their slaves and then
they took credit that's a
historical question i can really tell
that they invented was
like the idea of the toothbrush because
they believe that they're the only
people stupid enough to stick a freaking
stick in their
mouth and push it around yeah okay
also what i find really suspicious is
that the only person really vouching for
uh jerusalem and israel and their stance
on
political and more scenarios is benjamin
and i noticed that his wife is from an
arab country
um but it's just kind of weird like if
you look at the israelis like i know
they're mixed with a lot of
um middle eastern asian people
and it is like how do i know
that they didn't switch places like how
do i know yeah it's getting pretty weird
hey david um big fan of your show and
was just wondering what you
um what your thoughts on um masks
uh being worn um with the new variant
being out
um i think it was in cali they said that
people should
uh still wear masks um because of the
variant
yeah i mean i'm mostly doing everything
outside right now
and um i i assume that um
by the fall there's gonna be a lot more
masking is my
is my expectation that's that's my sense
of it
looks like here's another one about
masks
hi david um i'm calling about
something you said on your show
regarding the flu season
um you know people wearing their masks
and it'll
it'll help with the flu because look
what happened
um this past year at you know
the mask wearing helped keep us
keeping oh crap
okay
this is a comment in response to your
video about
the um the the dod documentation saying
that
socialists are terrorists
in any type of economic ideology there's
going to be good and bad
communism good and bad closing isn't
good and bad capital is good and bad
and actually a lot of different um
countries use
okay so that just cut out
it's weird uh
let's keep going hey david
um look man this is why i love you i get
to listening and
my brain just starts turning over with
ideas so i was listening to you talk
about
uh why we do a minimum wage and
that it comes down to this balance
between the wage
versus the government assistance which
is ultimately paid for by the taxpayer
um so the
the thing is taxpayers shouldn't be
subsidizing big businesses i mean they
they make bajillions of dollars a year
they have these millions of dollars of
bonuses for the ceos and such and
and and some of them pay little to zero
uh
taxes you know every year so so as you
can tell it's like that's
it's a very nice voicemail but it's not
anything i can sort of use like on the
broadcast show
i do want to say thank you to grungy dan
for dropping in a twitch
sub via twitch prime and his new member
number eight today
today is a perfect day actually to re-up
those twitch prime subs in advance of
jeff bezos being launched
um up into the air of course as all of
you know
sir your wife is up in the air jeff
bezos going up very soon but he can't
take the bezos bucks with him so a great
day
to uh drop in one of those twitch subs
um let's continue with
the voicemails hey david
my name is also dave and i'm from san
diego i was just calling because
i was wanting to uh ask a question
i was recently listening to the band
called stick to your guns and on
one of their tracks i'm on there beyond
the sun
at the end of the track i recognized
your voice
as chang's voice and i'll show you if
you had any
knowledge of that you could hear any
yeah they asked about it and their
friends of the show
stick to your guns a progressive uh
progressive minded
band and yes that's very cool and we're
very very much aware of that
hey dave it's denver uh i really enjoyed
uh you coming on to stream today when
you're on vacation
and all the jokes about uh matthew
calamari were really funny
squid pro quo etc but can you imagine
if there were a guy named dave rubin
that might be just a little bit too
absurd i don't know
tell me what do you think bye okay very
interesting we're just continuing we're
going one after the other that's why
this keeps happening
hey david hey i hear often that
sometimes you get a caller
um when you take phone calls because i
guess you don't have anything else to do
or any topic to talk about this is troy
york now
and they say that people we should
ignore trump
and that the media should not cover
trump and
um because they don't like him
politically and his pro-american views
and many of these callers by the way i
have noticed
perhaps you haven't are german
or they say they're australian
they're not even this is so dumb i'm so
bored with troy york it's just
it's so boring
so it's looking at the biggest
population
um in america as far as like immigration
goes
um is indians um
which is this i'm also sick of
uh going on talking about like the
indian people
yep and we're not going to do that i do
want to say thank you to blueberry babe
for signing up via twitch prime at
twitch.tv
david pakman also thanks to fino 963
who just signed up in his new member
number 10 and says for goodness sake
this girl is so self-absorbed happy day
david peace
also want to thank matthew calamari for
gifting
one twitch prime subscription via twitch
i very much appreciate that we do have
the coupon code sad trump it's in play
um let's let's uh let's in fact
test some of these coupon codes because
i believe that they are all working
how much of a discount is sad trump
let's see
sad trump
oh hold on something's gl maybe it's not
working oh my god
let's refresh here if we can coupon code
sad trump there it is 180 a month it was
like too big of a discount yeah
it's working fine guys sad trump is
working and there's absolutely no
problem whatsoever with that okay
let's uh let we we can we can ease up on
the it's not working stuff
all right let's go to a couple just a
couple more of these a couple more of
these all right
um i i mean the same i think this is the
same woman who called in
there's like um miscommunication kind of
i feel like among
um the
i guess like moral superiority of um
what happened during the circuit because
i feel like there's
maybe some people yeah i don't think
we're gonna do there was confusion about
nazis no we're not do we're not going
down that road
i want to say thank you to joseph rader
for both resubscribing with prime and
gifting a subscription putting us at 13.
also thanks to jen here for gifting a
subscription number 14.
um let's look at maybe
maybe let's just do there's so many from
the same caller i guess the rule is i'm
not skipping
it's really hard for me to like um trust
people who
hail hitler and stuff like that me too
yep me too i
i definitely agree with that yeah hey uh
david uh it's eric from mass i'm just
calling to let you know that the who
has said that uh no longer should kids
take the facts it's very dangerous you
can look it up man i'm just
yeah that's not what they said uh and we
haven't even really started vaccinating
kids 12 plus only with one vaccine very
strange caller very dangerous caller in
fact
uh let's keep going hey david this is
steve
from milwaukee wisconsin i just have a
quick question for you
um i think there's a real divide between
uh
democrats and republicans on what
foreign nations we think
the real threat is now you can make some
good arguments for china
the fact that their economy is booming
so much
uh you make the argument for russia
because there's depends what you mean by
threat also
attacks and their investment into what
i'd like to say is a new
cold war of misinformation and uh you
know hacking voting systems this and
that so
in your opinion david um who is the
biggest threat to the united states
and uh i i think that that's very black
white thinking
are we talking a geopolitical threat
economic threat terroristic threat
domestic threat
culture you know it's we've got to be
more specific about it i think
all right let's um
[Music]
let's listen to one more hi patreon
david um
and it happens to be troy york the
program i just want to let you know
i've seen um programs of jimmy dora
uh who basically
he has uh mocked uh
sam cedric um he has done a video now on
kyle kogunski who cares who cares
i don't know what's going on guys i have
no idea about this stuff
a secular talk and i think that
uh we need to be forewarned and not to
mess
uh not to [ __ ] around with jimmy dore
because he will
eventually put a video for the david
patton
my my channel is significantly larger
than jimmy's i don't know i mean it
seems it would benefit him to start
doing that which he might but what i did
i don't care i don't know what these
guys are doing like what are the
is what's maybe people in the chat can
tell me are they all constantly
criticizing each other
in order to get clicks is that what's
going on
like i don't even get what what how is
this every single week
it's jank jimmy dore and
kyle and that's basically what it is
yeah okay
uh i guess i'll listen to a little bit
more and i think
that um jimmy dore
is setting it straight to you far left
radical marxists
marxists or marxixts what was that word
and um he's not a guy to be played
around with
oh and hopefully um
your goofy argentine bends away lynas
i've never been to venezuela doesn't um
propagandize and attack him like the
aforementioned
awful podcasters um
timmy dora bash the lincoln projects
rick wilson
who cares he has bashed the psychopath
keith olbermann and he has
uh blasted the stupid sam cedar
yeah all right well you know good
good for him i guess like is it a badge
of honor to be bashing people as opposed
to doing policy i don't know you guys
tell me i don't i don't really get it
um let's see
here what else are we doing
uh maybe just one more
hey david i was seeing that hurricane
elsa is about to swing through florida
and it sparked a thought do you think
when trump drew alabama
in the map of that hurricane it was
coming from
parker all right and we're done okay
that's gonna be i've
we're done with voicemails for the time
being okay south texas rover says been a
yearly member and
never heard a bonus show oh that's
really easy
um when you oh hold on a second let's
see if i can let me get myself logged
in
just so we can we can i'll show you
where that is
uh okay so when logged in you just go to
member
content and you pick the year like right
now it's 2021 so you would go to member
content 2021
and you just click on whatever bonus
show you want
just you just click that's it it's super
super simple
bonus shows and boner shows are all on
the same page yeah
so you don't you don't have to go to two
different places for that david have you
seen today's guardian newspaper kremlin
files exposed yep that's on our that's
on our podcast today
tokyo olympics will be held without
spectators number of severe cases 400
and death 20 per day but only 30 percent
finished with first facts what do you
think of the decision
probably makes sense we actually i'll
i'll actually show you guys something
that's going to be published a little
bit later
to uh youtube um that we did on today's
show by the way thanks to captain doncho
and gatsby cat for the twitch subs
numbers 15 and 16.
let me find this actually no you know
what this is not even on until
tomorrow's show so let me play
this is so bizarre a guest went on fox
news
and referred to the japanese genocide
and well why did it turn green that's
weird and nobody corrects her listen to
this she's got japan
and china confused around these olympics
i like to call them the genocide
olympics anyway i'm i'm still on the
team that i'm not even sure that we
should be
competing because there is an ongoing
genocide in xinjiang
look at look at uh kaylee nodding so if
they're if we are going to go to a
country if we are going to compete and
have american athletes there
uh in a country that's committing a
genocide even more important harris to
have
the freedom of the american flag wow
yeah except japan is not committing a
genocide against the uyghurs
it's just not happening japan has
criticized the genocide against the
weakers
um what a bizarre thing now i i saw one
comment and i'll address this tomorrow
i saw one comment that um
uh she meant next year's beijing
olympics
this was a segment about the olympics
happening
in in 10 days like if i if i refer to
the olympics
and the olympics start in 10 days it's
sort of like if the world cup we're
starting tomorrow
and four years from now it's in like
saudi arabia it's actually in guitar
coming up but in any case
and i go yeah we shouldn't even go to
the world cup and then
who would assume i'm talking about the
one four years from now
it's very strange but i think a lot of
people in the chat are making a good
point which is a lot of the fox news
audience has no idea what's going on so
they may not even notice
i want to say thank you to desiree de
long
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code
sad trump and his new member number
17 today very much appreciate that
let's look at uh a couple of other
super chats um hmq
says david oh no i already did that okay
started my own small business and it's
going well says jesus
excellent glad to hear it remember if
you want to stay in pace in space you
have to reach orbital velocity
many want bezos to stay in space
but his rocket lacks the oomph
wow that's interesting sir your wife is
up in the air
yeah a lot of people want bezos to just
stay up there steve gatter vinnie
colluda i'm a steve gad guy myself
big big fan of steve gad but vinnie's
great too
free idea clip the annoying voicemail
ladies voicemails into a clip and make
it a try not to cringe comp
compilation it'll make for an amazing
endurance workout that's not a bad idea
oh you guys want to hear an idea um this
is an idea for an upcoming stream okay
check this out
i have an idea for a game i'm gonna see
if i can have my team
set this up the game is i'm gonna play
the game and we could all play it
together on an upcoming stream the game
is going to be called
bobby fischer or gnome chomsky okay now
why bobby fischer near the end of his
life
this was his look okay
gnome chomsky now also has
uh sort of a similar similar look at
this point in time there's just sort of
like a similar look okay
the game is going to be as follows i'm
going to be given a quote
in writing and i'm going to read the
quote and the game is
i have to decide is that a bobby fischer
quote
or is that a gnome chomsky quote
after i guess we'll actually have a clip
and we'll play the clip and we'll see if
i can guess whether it was noam chomsky
who said it
or bobby fisher who said it i think this
is the best game
and obviously it's going to be uh like
my team is going to have to set it all
up for me and give me
the quote images and then the files
and because you know it needs to be done
in a way where i'm not going to know
but i think that this is a fantastic
fantastic game i'm going to email the
team about it and hopefully
maybe even by next week we could we've
got a lot going on but maybe by next
week we could have it ready
um jacob ratner says
sir how do we stop republican
whitewashing
uh of january 6. sure sure
uh we it's just we've got to just keep
going and continue to point out uh
continue to point out that they're not
telling the truth there's really no
other way to do it
it's just a matter of repetition i want
to say thank you to chris mitsukopoulos
chris mitzikopoulos has just signed up
on joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code sad trump and his
new member
number 18 today i really appreciate that
chris
and uh yeah trump's existence has just
become so sad
that that's the the those are the
oranges
of the coupon code sad trump maddie says
sir i left you a very power voicemail
please read it on air i don't know that
i'm able to read a voicemail
i don't know how we do that it's um
it's complex let me see if i've got any
other things here
keep on the good work um
we're also going to listen to an email a
little bit later
it's going to be pretty wild not going
to lie okay
um i don't know if we want to get into
this
uh oh you know what let's just get into
it so i've been asked asked
to react to a ben shapiro clip i don't
know what we're about to see
let's just dive in it looks like we have
a little bit of time
to get a flight out of town uh at a time
certain with
you know getting everybody to come in
from across the state you need to fly
privately
i need to fly private i can't fly with
the peasants
the peasants smell and have chickens
and now in order to fight the supposed
republican jim crow assault
this means that democrats have every
ability to undermine the actual
functioning
workings of democracy it's really
impressive what what is he talking about
unbelievable gaslighting and flip here
so the idea here is that republicans are
subverting elections by saying that
voters
should have verifiable means of voting
that is subverting elections that is the
new jim crow
of course that's not that's a distortion
of what text texas republicans are
trying to
strategically uh restrict voting in
order to benefit
um in order to benefit uh themselves
that's what they're trying to do
meanwhile texas texas democrats in order
to stymie republicans from pursuing this
new jim crow
get to simply abscond from the state of
texas violate the law
and shut down basic majoritarian
democracy in texas
and unlike on the national level where
we have a 50 50 split in the senate
there is no 50 50 split in texas
republicans have an overwhelming
majority
in the state assembly in texas and so
democrats came up with a strategy they
didn't want to pass this voter id law
they didn't want to pass a couple of
bills that suggested that boys should
play with boys and girls with girls
in sports and so they got on a plane and
they flew to washington dc
in order to deny republicans a quorum
and these are the heroes of the day
according to the media yeah i mean
listen i don't think that they're heroes
and ultimately i think they're going to
lose but democrats just never fight so
i'm glad to see them try something it
will at least
call attention to the reaction from
republicans which was
let's see if we can arrest the democrats
that was the reaction from many
republicans so
i admire that democrats are doing
something is it some big
moral victory no it's not and ultimately
they're going to lose on this because as
ben points out they don't have the
majority
but what on earth is he talking about if
you undermine democracy
by simply walking out of the chamber and
leaving the states so you camp
the voter suppression bill undermines
democracy
they're trying to pass a bill to
undermine democracy be brought back to
the chamber to vote in majoritarian
fashion
now you're a hero you see the filibuster
is bad a long-held standard in the
united states senate that's supposed to
promote
debate and and conciliation that's
really bad and anti-democratic but
if an entire political party in texas
picks up that's on a private jet
and flies to washington dc while patting
themselves on the back in order to deny
the workings of democracy that's not
only not anti-democratic it is
pro-democratic you see
yeah i mean again it's this is mostly
straw men ben shapiro is taking down
strawmen
um i've not seen
call what texas democrats did some kind
of incredible act of heroism
it's like you you don't have the
majority
and they're trying republicans in texas
are trying to pass a bill
to stifle voting rights so they are
getting attention on what's going on and
the attention is leading to
texans calling their elected officials
and saying don't pass this bill don't
pass this bill
they figured out a way to get attention
on this and republicans reacted by
saying
let's send texas state troopers to
arrest the democrats
so it's not some incredible heroic thing
but it's an interesting way given that
you don't have the majority and the
majority
is trying to use their power to make it
harder for people to vote to get some
attention on what's going on that's it
it's not so black and white it's not
it's not the you know he's putting up a
straw man and then taking it down
now you may be saying yourself i i don't
see a consistent standard here correct
you don't
no it's you're not even telling the
truth about what's being said is none
there's no consistent standard when it
comes to the democratic party and the
media the answer is whatever
forwards the agenda is good and whatever
does not for the agenda is jim crow
and joe biden is fully on board with
this because the way you hold political
power according to joe biden
is you gin up an enormous amount of faux
outrage
and then you claim that your political
opponents are the equivalent of george
wallace standing in a schoolhouse door
oh god here we go okay so texas
democrats have sconded
over the course of the last couple of
days they just picked up and they got a
private jet and they left
and they partied it up in fact uh they
were they were bragging about what a
wonderful time they were having in
washington d.c these are true emissaries
of the people by the way they got in a
private jet
and they brought along a case of miller
light just in case any of them decided
that uh their drinking habit
couldn't last for the how is this even
remotely relevant to the 250 bills
proposed after the november election to
make it harder for people to vote
that's the issue miller lite private
jets
maybe these are important details uh to
some people
but there's 250 bills trying to restrict
voting rights four hour flight from
texas from austin to to washington dc
gene wu a texas legislator tweeted out
a a picture of what appears to be a
caesar salad with croutons
he said my fist meal as a fugitive i
assume he meant a first
meal i i don't wanna know what he does
in the privacy of his own home he's my
fist meal as a fugitive
delicious what a hero and then he
tweeted there's not even anything to
respond
it's just so dumb guys it's so so so
dumb
uh i don't i don't know what else to
even say about it who watches that and
it just doesn't make any sense
um okay dive down set let's read some
super chats keep it going david how can
people not see republican voter
suppression but i am for voter id
countries in europe has it but voter id
should be for free
right so here's the thing i am not
opposed to voter id and principle
i am not opposed to voter id and
principle i am not opposed to voter id
and principle
i am oh hold on uh the problem is that
when you change the rules
right when you change the rules you have
to
think about how is it being what is the
on-ramp
for the rule change and do
what documents are required to get the
id
where how many places in the state can
you get those documents
do any of the documents you need to get
your free id
costs money who is going to be unable if
it takes you know if you can only get
some of these documents nine to five
monday through friday
who is going to be able to
disproportionately get that time off to
go and get what they need versus not
okay so so it's far more complex than
they want to make it out to be but
in principle i am not opposed to needing
an id to vote it's the implementation
that is being proposed that i am uh
opposed to
buxon6 david any tip tips on learning to
speak
spanish could you recommend a program i
really couldn't i have no idea i mean i
i just learned spanish being born in
argentina so i don't know i don't know
does shapiro
sound like mandark from dexter's lab i
don't know what that is
uncle joe meets with mooty merkel we are
in good hands mooty means mother
okay dang old tell ya what
bobby says simply sir
sir sure um okay
and i think that gets me caught up as
far as
super chats are concerned i do want to
say thanks to some really
really great people who just signed up
on my website paul
scott just signed up with the coupon
code sad
trump and his new member number 19 today
also a big thank you to kevin thompson
who signed up with the coupon code sad
trump
and his new member number 20. and then
philip
kitschke i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
also signing up with the coupon code sad
trump
and his new member number 21
very much appreciate that also thanks to
andrew williams
cybersec who signed up via twitch prime
and his new member number 22. um i
actually
would be interested today in speaking to
kenny
also known to some as stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
if we have time let me see if i can
check in with him hey are you live right
now
want to check in um because i do want to
talk to him about this
gusano thing that's going on he says
yeah sure okay all right let's see if we
can connect with steven real quick um
let's see what's going on here hold on
input device
output device
let's see yeah are we sam
stephen that's my name hey how are you
well i'm doing great i wish i could say
the same for your audience that has to
suffer through our conversation now how
are you doing
are you are you traveling right now no
i'm actually just got home a while ago
oh okay okay okay okay got it got it
so we we did a review earlier of this um
uh you know the whole gusano thing you
commenting on hassan and the entire
thing you know what i'm talking about
yeah that's it's my life so yeah i know
quite well i lived it
you in other words you remember the
segment in question
oh i don't remember your particular
segment but i remember doing it all
yesterday yeah no you that's what you
remember that that was yesterday that
you were remember
yeah yeah i remember it quite vividly
yeah yeah so i mean i'm i'm basically
with you
i stay away from any well i i i find it
to be a racialized term because it's
disproportionately applied to
white latin americans like me although
the white supremacists say i'm not white
because i'm jewish but that's a that's a
story for a different day you know
but i try to stay away from any of these
racialized uh terms
and uh it's just it's just not for me i
tend to agree with your take on it
my favorite part is that like it's fun
because i've like i fought with so many
different sides of the political isle
is uh is people will say things like
well actually it's not racialized
because cuban is not an ethnicity
which is technically true however i
remember i argued a lot about
against those arguments four or five
years ago when i would hear weird things
where like republicans were saying [ __ ]
like i don't want any dirty [ __ ]
muslims in this country
i don't want any mexicans and i'd be
like that's a little bit racist and
they'd always go like well actually
mexican is it's a nationality yeah and
i'm like okay chief come on right
yeah i just thought it's really weird
because it's like cause you wouldn't
call me gusano you didn't happen to know
that my mom was cuban so that's a really
weird
like insult to use like and i've
actually never had it's funny because
people on the right that i've debated
have never attacked me over like my
national
or ethnic background before but only
people on the left do which i think is
like really funny but
yeah i mean the other thing is it's not
i think it was it originally meant
anti-castro cubans but it's been widely
expanded just to be
basically be any off typically white
central or south american who disagrees
with these sort of faux left populist
regimes that's basically it
it'll apply it it's used for everybody
it's used against me it's
it's even broader now oh is it you are
it's my understanding is you're correct
in like the 50s or 60s or whatever i
think fidel castro started calling the
anti-revolutionary cubans
gusanos or at least i think that's where
the originals lose for cubans um but
nowadays it's just if you have
any background that's like caribbean or
south american or whatever and you're
not like
far left you're just a gusano oh okay
literally yeah it's even more broad
yeah would you say at this point that
you're the most prominent
cuban-american streamer on twitch i'm
not actually sure
maybe i'm trying to think who else there
is
sure there's somebody out there yeah no
i mean i think that that
that's something that we could maybe
leverage in some way
well when you figure out how to leverage
it just let me know yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean and now just to be clear because
i know some people are going to run to
hassan
i i'm glad to talk to hassan about this
i would have him on
you know i have no prayer this is not
i'm not involving myself in any i just i
think it's
just an issue about which we can
disagree
right or or is that that you're not your
take the problem is that like
i mean at the end of the day it's i
really i actually don't give a [ __ ]
about it that much i just feel it's
funny that people that
like woke signals so hard over so many
things will like are frothing
the mouth to like try to call me some
type of weird slur i think that's
[ __ ] funny um yeah but i mean at the
end of the day
it's what it is what it is whatever been
called worse things by lefties
what uh what else like what arcs are you
currently involved in
um well i don't know i guess well right
now we're doing the
cubist stuff a little bit where people
think that the embargo that we've had
for 60 years has just
like now magically caused all this
horrible [ __ ] to happen in cuba and it
couldn't have possibly been anything
else it's definitely the embargo
um and then i don't know other random
[ __ ] has been going on
just been talking about yeah my take on
i mean i
might i don't know exactly what you've
said about cuba but my take on cuba has
been the following
i've been against the embargo for a long
time because i think it's hypocritical
and it also is not going to achieve what
it was originally meant to achieve which
is to like
force a change of the system of
government in cuba at the same time
i'm a progressive and i'm an
anti-authoritarian so there's no planet
on which i'm going to say
the 50-year military regime where the
leaders wear the military uniforms
and there's no real elections i'm for
that in any way and somebody called me
up and said yeah but david you're not
understanding that
castro came to power because of real
cuban protests
against a terrible administration that
was in place in the early 50s
i'm completely on board with that but
i'm not going to support the 1959 to
2021 regime like that's just there's
nothing progressive about that
yeah i mean i'm not a fan of the current
government but
maybe i'm just optimistic i i feel like
the embargo is really dumb like
it's it's hard for me to imagine that
like
cuba is so close to the us like if we
were trading and we had like a [ __ ]
ton of tourists flying back
and forth and [ __ ] do we not think that
like the as the economy liberalizes the
people who chill a little bit more like
i don't know i just i feel like having
it having an enemy like off like [ __ ]
50 miles away from key west is
really strange i wish that we would just
[ __ ] off all the embargo [ __ ] and just
go back to trading with him
of course when obama started to thaw
kind of the relations and all those
flights opened up that were going
through
havana and [ __ ] but trump completely and
totally 180 on [ __ ] all of it
and the problem is that all of our
embargo [ __ ] is like so
deeply embedded across like five or six
different pieces of legislation
that getting rid of it is gonna require
so much political capital that
democrats basically have to say like
okay we're just going to acknowledge
that we're never winning florida again
for the next [ __ ] 50 years because
i'm speaking as a cuban
holy [ __ ] cubans hate the country of
cuba
yeah yeah yeah i was just um i was
actually just in miami
and i had a bunch of cuban uh lyft
drivers
and you know it's very interesting
because
they're not republicans in the wacky
trumpian sense where like the first 70
of my conversation with them was very
very reasonable
and then all of a sudden it's like oh
yeah they voted for trump because they
saw biden as an
actual communist who was going to play
koi with cuba it's very
it's a it's a weird thing because it's
not like meeting some q anon conspiracy
theorist you know it's a very
it's a unique thing actually cuban cuban
conservatism
yeah people and i'm trying hard to
you're you're you're walking me through
all of the audience pitfalls that makes
your audience hate me so i blame you for
this
but um a lot of very young white
americans
have don't understand that there are a
lot of brown
south africans that come to the us that
don't really have the most positive
views of socialism
um that there are a lot of people
believe it or not that genuinely left
cuba
um in the first in the in the first the
the first
exodus um i think in the early 60s a lot
of those were like political dissidents
like batista supporters people that
legitimately did hate the revolution
there were a lot more after that there
were the whole freedom flights the
mayoral boat lifts like right and those
were a lot of people that were just like
yo
this country [ __ ] sucks ass now um
and a lot of these people
um uh i'm sorry south americans not
south africans my bad
um there were there were a lot of people
that just legitimately left because like
yeah my bed because the country's
legitimately falling apart
um and then same thing with people that
come from like venezuela and [ __ ] like
there are a lot of people there are a
lot of brown south americans
that have really bad experiences with
like socialist regimes and then when
they come to the us and you've got all
these like young white kids
that are the most capitalist iphone
posting tweeting [ __ ] in the
world
talking about how great socialism and
communism [ __ ] is a lot of these people
look at them like
i don't know about that chief not to say
that anybody's right or wrong i'm just
saying that
their lived experiences aren't going to
jive well with like the you know
terminally online incessant twitter
poster
yeah this is actually uh there's this
assumption i think
the the wright loves to play this up but
sometimes the left also believes it
that basically immigrants to the us are
just liberal period
and there's a bunch of different groups
where it's not the case like for example
i had
a chinese caller recently who explained
i think he's in his 20s parents you know
whatever however old that would make
his parents that a lot of those uh
chinese immigrants are of that uh
generation
are also sort of like center right again
they're not queuing on people they're
not it's not that they're they're not uh
evangelical christians or anything like
that but they're they're sort of
center-right i have a
a ukrainian friend who said basically
all of his russian friends not ukrainian
but russian friends
they're all trump people even in
relatively blue states like new york
connecticut or massachusetts
the immigrants are not just uniformly on
the left the way many people think
yeah like the problem and this is
actually scary for me because like
i think that the republican party has a
huge crisis right now
because it's not really the republican
party there's a lot of those people that
are literally now just trump loyalists
period yeah
um and so you're seeing this weird thing
happening in the republican party
where all these republican lawmakers
they still have to simp for trump
because they have to because they're all
of their yeah otherwise they're never
getting elected again
um i feel like one of the only ways the
republican party can kind of like work
its way back and trump did a really good
job at this
and the left did a really bad job of
this is appealing to right leading
voters
i'm sorry not rightly voters right
leaning voters of color i guess
oh okay okay yeah um yeah like people on
the left don't realize this but
when it comes to social issues um
like person i don't know persons of
color non-white voters in the united
states
tend to fall more to the right than the
average white person whether we're
talking about stuff like gay marriage or
lgbt acceptance or whatever
um or like things like traditional
gender roles right again as somebody
that's cuban like i've
heard like i think my sister might have
even had a um
is it a quinceanera i think where they
celebrate like their 15th
birthday party yeah yeah there are
people that still do this [ __ ] that are
very traditional or whatever
and if and i've always said this with
republicans it's the big danger
if republicans could just stop being so
[ __ ] racist
right um they would actually have so
many allies in like the islamic
communities
and in in the black communities and in
like the mexican communities that come
up to the united states like you would
have so many allies there if you could
just look past the
the fact that they're a different skin
color than you uh right with under trump
that started to happen you
there were a lot of hispanic people that
surprised people in the us like wow a
lot of these [ __ ] are voting
republican what's going on
also a cab and get rid of all the police
i was like okay well you know like
yeah yeah the um there's a bunch of
stuff there i mean
the the prop 8 vote in california
exposed that
there there's definitely the potential
that the republican party could do much
better with black voters who
because of religious connections were
not thrilled with the idea of gay
marriage when the prop 8 vote took place
um
central and south americans
overwhelmingly catholic although it's
important to know that like they're
central and south american catholics are
are not necessarily catholics
in the sense that we sometimes imagine
in the us but still
if there was better outreach from the
republican party there's a real risk
that they would many of them would vote
that way
and obviously the florida 2020 was an
example of that
yeah i mean catholics aren't quite like
evangelical no
but i think that they're definitely more
to the right socially
although that has changed at least in my
catholic communities
in the past 20 years a bit um in terms
of being more accepting of like gay
people in the
congressions concessions um in your
church or whatever
um but but i think that yeah catholics
yeah you're not it's
it's congressional right i have no idea
i have no you mean
you're um you're like your church your
uh
congregation yeah congregation oh okay
yeah there you go you're the members of
your church yeah if they would if they
would do more outreach to those people
and not be as so crazy racist towards
them i think that there is a lot of
potential republican support
from those communities i totally agree
yeah need to or
democrats need to be more cognizant of
that well democrats have benefited
by not seeing as much abandonment by
those groups
because as you're pointing out of the
racism and the incompetence
that takes place at the federal level
but at the local level
you see a lot more uh republicans who
are people of color
in local positions city councils and
this type of thing and every once in a
while they go through and it's like you
know the per
the people that trump will point to and
say uh this this is the guy i like right
like whether it's tim scott or whoever
else but that's actually a lot more
common
in local positions school boards and
this type of thing which the right kills
the left on
that's one of the reasons why i'm like
and i know that we all have like
different issues that we want people to
focus on but yeah
if this i feel like i think does bina
call them
uh kitchen table issues yeah i think
like the infrastructure bill goes
through and we get like all of this
like the child tax credit that should be
going through and everything i feel like
those types of programs will hopefully
bolster
the view of the democratic party and
like at least like the average working
person's
eyes instead of focusing so much on the
goddamn culture war [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] police [ __ ] on the like
being hyper fixated on like the medicare
for all policy like if we could just
focus like hey
how do we get a lot of money to american
workers to poor people to people's
children
like i think that those are the issues
that will bolster um
the eyes of the average person in the
democratic party
yeah but at the same time when i talked
to rachel bittikoffer about this
yesterday i don't know if you know her
um when the right is not even pretending
to care about policy and they're just
doing the culture stuff and saying
the the left is dangerous you've got to
fear the left communism socialism
they'll take your house they'll take
your kids they'll take your schools all
this different stuff
just talking about economic policy i
don't know that it it's a
strong enough way to fight it i don't
know about that while that is
true and these this is all just feelings
i have i feel like the feeling is
because
for whatever reason because they don't
have the the government in place to do
it like they don't own
enough of congress to get these things
passed i feel like the reason is because
the left is really good at talking about
economic policy
but it's so hard to legislate it yeah
but i think that
and i i could be wrong but like if
you're actually
getting a 300 check every single month
from the government for your kid
and that came off the back of a
republican congress and not a single
goddamn republican legislator signed on
to any of this stuff
that man that has to resonate at some
level i would hope i hope to god maybe
it won't maybe yeah
maybe you're right maybe it will all
still come down to like well is he prior
or anti-abortion
but isn't that isn't that gonna be
ancient history by november of 22.
um i don't know i mean like that's a man
like just going by my so as somebody
that
i just started getting into streaming
when i had a child so i didn't have to
do
i didn't have to suffer financially
thank god while i had a kid
although right up to the moment of being
him being born and everything
we my like we had wic um which stands
for women's and infinite children
because we were trying to qualify for
food aid and everything
300 a month for a kid and that's like
that's awesome
yeah that's in some states if the father
is poor enough that's a [ __ ] child
support payment you know
that's a lot of money and that 300 a
month that's
only the um that's only the the like the
fronted half of that child tax credit
right because you still get um oh no no
if you get the 300 a month that's
different
um you you wouldn't qualify for the rest
of that account but that's still like
that's a really big payment every single
month that's i feel like that has to be
noticeable
like it would it would blow my mind but
maybe not again i i just i hope for the
best because
yeah right right now the biggest concern
is a lot of poor people
um don't actually file taxes
they just they don't they just work they
get their whatever and they don't file
and if you don't owe any money to the
irs i don't think they actually care if
you file or not
i don't know enough about that i would i
don't know enough about it to say yeah
there's a lot of poor workers with
children unfortunately don't file taxes
so they're not going to be able to
register for the 300 a month and a lot
of these people don't have internet
access they're not internet savvy yeah
the government website is kind of a mess
i don't know if you ever tried setting
up through the
exchanges oh my god yeah i mean i do uh
yeah i i the exchanges because i just
buy my own health insurance since we're
not my business isn't big enough for us
to have like a group plan
not only are the plans terrible but the
system's terrible i mean it's all
terrible
yeah yeah so i i hope that a lot of poor
people figure out how to get access to
that i know there are
i think medlock and a few other people
are trying to like get more people to
like raise awareness for it on twitter
but um yeah hey let me ask you this
where are you on this whole billionaire
space race thing
oh i think it's awesome i've always
wanted to go to space
and i think that when you start like any
like new fledgling industry
is probably going to have the richest
people participate that's my guess
um so like yeah it makes sense if we're
starting to do space tourism it's going
to be really expensive initially so it's
probably going to be billionaires doing
it initially but the idea that like 20
years from now
you could pay like two thousand dollars
to get like a ticket to like
go to like low earth orbit and like
float around for a bit and come back
that sounds so cool to me
yeah i mean i i'm sensitive to the
argument that people make where it's
like for what's being spent on this you
could basically end poverty or
hunger or whatever but like it's clear
it's clear those people are not going to
put the money into that um and and also
i mean the per capita costs for any new
technology at the beginning are very
very high and we don't even know what
other things are going to come
from this i i am i am a fan of it but i
do recognize that on a per capita basis
like
the carbon footprint of this flight next
week with bezos and i guess it's his
brother and like a kid and
four people or whatever the the per
capita cost
and carbon footprint is completely nuts
but that's not unique to this like
there's so many areas where that's the
way it is at the beginning
i don't know i have a hard time being
like mad about it although i don't i'm
not like a big
bezos guy you know i'm not like a bezos
cultist or anything like that
i mean like i think that the um i think
that the
the problem is a lot of people don't
understand like the orders of magnitude
that we're talking about like
and i could be wrong enough to go look
but i just did a quick google search my
understanding is that they're spending
like
like in terms of how much bezos is
personally spending it's gonna be on the
scale of like a hunt like
in the tens or hundreds of millions
right or less than that yeah
that like when you're talking about like
food entitlement programs in their
country you're on the scale of trillions
you're you're this is like drops in the
bucket is the are food
are food stamps trillions though i'm not
sure about that
well like well when you're talking about
like you you said things like ending
poverty or ending hunger right
yeah okay yeah you're not doing it with
100 million dollars no you're right
about that you have to get into the at
least the like
tens or hundreds of billions most likely
the trillions before you even begin to
touch that you know
yeah no i don't i don't disagree with
that uh
well wow okay i mean it's uh it seems
like things are would you
are you do you feel like you're in the
an upswing right now from the standpoint
of your streaming business and
everything that you're doing is it a
lull is it a decline
um i've chilled for a few months just
like playing a lot of league because
this platform scares me because i never
know how to get banned for saying
something that i think is
non-controversial but i just got back
from a vacation so we're watching stuff
we're reading stuff
um yeah did you go did you go anywhere
interesting
um i went down to key west oh really two
days what is it like there i was just in
miami and there were
you know i did there i didn't see uh uh
too many people
in miami when i was there uh june 25th
oh okay okay i was in miami i guess like
a week ago sorry i didn't miss you again
it was pretty pretty nuts in miami i'm
not gonna lie what do you mean by nuts
i don't know it's just it's uh uh let me
just put it this way if i were not
vaccinated i would have been very
stressed during the trip
oh yeah that well florida's been like
that the whole time yeah it wouldn't
surprise me actually
florida was safer than most places now
because most of those people have
probably been [ __ ] affected by
that right yeah they're not vaccinated
but they may have they they may have the
recovery immunity at this point
how many vaccines have you gotten so far
um so i just did my third um
i just finished my third second shot of
the one so you're up to six
okay uh no oh just the pfizer okay
do you only watch um
oh god i was gonna get a lord of the
rings but i remember the names of the
movies
hello um yeah i got a lot of vaccines no
um i had my two physical shots a while
ago
um and i feel pretty okay um
it's pretty sad i think probably there's
a few things that have happened i'm not
like a big like i hate america
uh person uh but the the vaccine
situation
is something that i am so unimaginably
disappointed on
yeah it's completely demoralizing yeah
i mean it's like there's people in
countries all over the world
desperate for these vaccines desperate
and here it's like you can just walk in
anywhere and it's just like nah i don't
think i'm gonna get it
nah just not gonna get it like my
understanding is that people in like
even canada or sweden um you'll get like
you you
book an appointment for a vaccine and
then like two months later you'll get
the first shot right and then you get
your second shot like
two months later uh and like molina came
over when i was getting my vaccines here
and she's from sweden and i went to the
store and they're like hey like if she
wants one too like you know we've got
extra slots like you know
and she got both of her pfizer vaccines
in the united states like that's how
available it is here
yeah it's crazy i don't even think we're
going to hit the 60
vaccinated rate it's unbelievable i
think we will hit 60 because we're doing
i mean it's pathetic but we're doing
like 500 000 shots a day
so i do think we'll get to 60 but it's
it's depressing
in fact when i landed in miami i had
a um uh lyft driver who said
he's not getting it because after his
mom's second shot she became totally
magnetic and metal stuff was sticking to
her
ah david i my mom when i talked to her
last were saying because
my dad had to get a shot because he
works at security at a nuclear power
plant and so they have teams and stuff
so they have to be vaccinated when i get
sick
and my mom actually told me that like
she was waiting a little bit to stick a
magnet to my dad's arm because she
hasn't gotten vaccinated yet she's like
65.
oh is that right yeah and it's actually
so incredibly frustrating we had an uber
driver in miami actually
i'm in south beach and me and my friend
were talking to this guy and oh my god
like he was a hispanic like he was
clearly like a spanish speaker like
speaking english as a second language
um not like some old white redneck guy
right talking about how
the simpsons predicted 911 and how
there's a lot of weird stuff with the
government
right trust any of that crazy vaccine
stuff and oh man i'm not gonna lie
david we inhabit this space but i will
say
i think that alternative media has been
one of the worst things to happen
to like the world um that this space has
been so incredibly talkative you're
saying because of all the conspiracy
stuff that just is out there
and it goes and there's just no that
there's one key
okay i'm curious if you get there is one
key thing that separates alternative
media from mainstream media you know
that one thing is it's a word that
starts with the letter
letter a a [ __ ] no
accountability talk about how like yeah
mainstream media messes things up about
and they do
but there is no accountability in
alternative media you can be like like
james o'keefe is a really good example
yeah you can get one thing wrong after
another after another after another
and who cares he's still o'keefe if it's
still projects he's still like a
top guest at cpac or whatever yeah yeah
it's insane
that's crazy yeah i remember five or six
years ago this should have been like
the dawning moment for me when um
because i grew up listening to
rush limbaugh um michael savage glenn
beck all the conservative guys and my
mom
i asked my mom like hey have you
listened to glenn beck recently how do
you feel because he's pretty anti-trump
you know so i'm curious what you think
about him
and my mom's like oh you know i don't
really listen to conservative stuff like
that anymore and i
was so happy and i was like they moved
on to online conspiracy nuttery though
correct they moved on to facebook memes
right right right right no that's that's
really it's crazy what's going on it's
it's just completely insane what are
your spots that you like in south beach
what are your what
what do you like to do in there um i
just have friends that live there and
then melina like really likes the beach
she's like a big beach person
yeah any restaurants that you recommend
um there's a cuban one my mom likes to
go do but it's way south in homestead
it's called uh mario's
oh it's not in south beach no no in
terms of like what's in south beach i
don't even know where we went i think we
just go to like chain
restaurants like steakhouses and
whatever are you oh so you're like a
ruth's chris guy and stuff like that
yeah or like a um what's the other one
called like is it fleming's am i making
that up
i have no idea yeah like stuff like that
i'm sure now here
i'm interested because you know you
you're you're a gentleman of a certain
uh
you know level of worldliness and your
cosmopolitan
and all of these different things what
makes you think hey i'm in south beach
there's all these
one-off restaurants and all this stuff
i'm gonna go to a chain how do you
what what's going on that that's what
you do
um well normally i just don't care that
much and i don't want to wait outside in
the
humid muggy heat for 35 minutes to get a
seat somewhere so
are you familiar with opentable um
there's like 30 of those apps on your
phone
you know maybe next time if i want to
plan out more maybe i'll do it okay yeah
next time i mean there's so many great
places like
do you like sushi you got blue ribbon
sushi in south beach
oh boy um silvano's which they had a
fire unfortunately but it's like a great
italian place and you've got the
sandwichery i mean there's just you know
i
i i think we've got to work on this as a
as the most prominent i would argue
and i will i will stand by it cuban
american streamer currently on twitch
i think you know we need to equip you
for some uh some of these cultural
experiences down there
yeah if you ever have recommendations if
people recommend me a restaurant i'll go
every day for sure it's just a matter of
like scheduling how to make sure it fits
in with what i'm doing and everything
can i just very briefly ask about the
seafood thing because not liking fish is
often one of those like childish things
that people grow out of but i know that
you're familiar
you're from nebraska so i'm assuming
that it's a childhood-based thing
yeah so like here's my issue i i think
that growing up
eating seafood in the midwest is way
different than eating on the coast
because
i've had like a lot of what i imagine is
pretty good sushi now in um
in la i had i had seafood in cancun it
was good um
i say quote-unquote good but i don't
really care for it but i think in the
midwest
um you didn't like it and you had no
frame of reference but it was pretty
good yeah because
seafood in the midwest i don't know how
to explain this something has it has a
very fishy taste
and it's very disgusting yeah like it
make it's just
ugh um but like eating fresh seafood
it's okay and i've
eaten like i i went with a friend um i
don't know if you know him he used to be
mtv superstar andy milonakis pretty big
deal
yeah that's a huge deal yeah but um he
cuz so he rattles me all the time
because he's like oh you need to try
more food steve um because we're on a
first-name basis because you know we're
really close to everything sure yeah but
he told me to uh go to a um there was
some sushi restaurant we went to where
it was like
it's like 200 the sev the chef serves
you
like 15 different types of sushi right
right right
an omakase a chef's tasting menu yeah
something like that yeah and i
and i ate it all and i thought it was
like okay but i would never in my life
go and order
like good seafood over like a really
good steak or something like i'm i'm
going to steakhouse every time that's
just my
maybe it'll change in the future i when
i went to cancun i ate seafood there and
it was like edible i could eat it not
throw up
but it's just like why would i ever get
something like this over like a really
good steak
or some really good like fried chicken
or some really good italian food or like
i just i don't know why i would do it
yeah
um this this take is scaring me i'm not
gonna lie kenny
well oh apparently the place was called
en naca
i don't know what if you've ever heard
of that or whatever oh yeah yeah yeah
right no i'm familiar with that yeah
yeah so but supposedly it's like a
little place it seats like i think like
15 people but um
yeah next time i'm in la let's me you
and andy go
and then i'll i'll analyze and report
back on the entire thing
okay sure yeah i'm good uh by the way
next time i'm in l.a me you and hassan
we're doing dinner again right
is that happening yeah let me know um
when you agree to that i'll be there
okay yeah okay good
all right stephen uh it's always it's
always a pleasure it seems like things
are really
advancing over there thanks you know i
try to advance things as much as i can
you know
all right we got biden and merkel coming
up so you you and i can catch up soon
uh-huh okay well i love everybody all
right take care love you see ya bye
all right there is stephen kenneth
destiny benell the second
what an appearance what an appearance
um i guess we should we should try with
hassan right i mean it's like
let's let's see what's going on with
hassan
hey are you streaming would love to
check in about
to check in about the gusano
situation if you're up for it
um let's see if hassan
is available and we're standing by for
joe biden he's now about an hour late
and should be starting any second um
okay yeah anyway i sent hassan a message
and i don't know uh he
he actually doesn't really respond to me
anymore interestingly but
[Music]
all right let's look at um a few
super chats here you said today trump
won the 16 primary without putin's help
but the republican-led senate intel
committee reported russia targeted
trump's opponents during the primary
and even further back okay yeah let me
revisit that then
um i'd rather a billionaire go into
space than it being nasa and taxpayer
funded in general space travel is a
frivolous waste of money i disagree that
it's frivolous i think we learn a lot
from it
oh and i'm sorry i've fallen so far
behind on so many things
i want to say thank you to blaze king
new jersey who is new member number 23
today i also want to thank desiree
de long who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code
sad trump and his new member number
24 today exactly i appreciate that
i would encourage you by the way drop in
uh you know drop in a twitch prime sub
or
sign up on my website it's all very
exciting
um can you prime sub on an iphone i have
no idea i've never used an iphone i was
handed one the other day and i didn't
know
how to even use it many west indian
immigrants
would be center right if republicans
weren't so blatantly racist yeah that's
exactly what we were talking about
exactly what we were talking about do
you know of hydro
and aeroponic agricultural techniques
when it comes to minimizing drought
these techniques use 90 less water most
water used is by agriculture want to see
your take on this i don't know enough
about it
that would be a great story though for
epic gardening to take
i think i would love to see a take from
epic gardening we actually had a great
call yesterday perfect phone call
hassan said he doesn't care about the
term and would rather jump off a bridge
man i i wonder if hassan doesn't like me
anymore that's interesting we used to
have a great relationship we hung out a
couple times
um like it's kind of it's interesting
maybe
maybe there's something about my
politics now where hassan has cut me off
i don't even really know
it's really weird we have a lot of
mutual friends and stuff where i i
you know you guys know i have no problem
uh
hassan's been talking about it all day
he doesn't like you're associated with
destiny i'm no more associated with
destiny than i am with him like the last
i mean
the last time i saw one of them i saw
the other we we we did the same thing we
just went to dinner it's kind of
interesting
let's see what's going on uh hassan
twitch
i'm curious what's happening over there
yeah it's interesting i mean i
i would actually be it would be sad if
if you cut me off
oh my god
[Music]
what on earth all right let's give it a
second
uh and we're still standing by for joe
biden by the way
um
[Music]
yeah no i don't know but i see a lot of
a lot of uh pretty aggressive rhetoric
here i don't really know about any of
that stuff
but um i can only report to you my
experience
let's see i think burning cross to a
black conservative who said being black
is lit
and he said oh is that oh wait so is he
just doing destiny content
be like oh my god i'm so offended that
people are using the term gusano
a term that most people had to [ __ ]
google immediately after i [ __ ]
mentioned it for the first time ever
and it's actually certainly not
political uh and uh
can only be used against cubans and uh
it's not just one
catch-all [ __ ] term that a lot of
leftist latin americans use
against people that they perceive to be
like capitalist anti-imperialist
counter-revolutionaries um you know
i'm i'm so offended i'm so offended what
it's just the same [ __ ] this dude
literally just uses
social justice and people of color as a
[ __ ] prop
just to like be like i'm so offended on
behalf of
everyone else he's no different than
he's like he's
the edgy what sjw with [ __ ] blue hair
okay that's all he is he literally just
weaponizes
social justice when it's appropriate and
then writes a [ __ ] manifesto
about trying to you know trying to
defend that like all the black people
calling him out for
saying the n word and private are
actually wrong and racist
what and racist like i'm sorry dude
once you say you know you want to mow
down [ __ ] blm protesters like you've
lost a high ground on an argument that
you want to make about [ __ ]
a political term that you are now
choosing to be offended
okay god damn usano is
literally in the same [ __ ] vein as
karen
a certain type of behavior which i'm
against yeah sex technically okay
and in the same vein as like saying
cracker or honky
or redneck it is a language it is a term
those are pretty bad terms guys i don't
know
have come up with to describe their the
conditions of their oppression
and the continued conditions of their
oppression by those who would wish to
oppress them i don't know most of the
people i see using the term gusano don't
seem
too too oppressed to me guys i don't
know about this is being absolutely
ridiculous having said that
do a lot of people on the left i guess
uh utilize this word against anyone that
they're like oh are you cuban well
you're a gosano
because you [ __ ] criticized cuba like
shut the [ __ ] up i think what he's
missing is the racial element of the
term
[ __ ] up like
just stop [ __ ] calling every human
person at gusano you're you're not
i haven't seen a hassan stream for a
while is this like
is this what it always is because i can
see i mean i
i see why he has so many followers
because it's like
rage high high level rage all the time
that i can see why he's doing so well i
mean good for good for hassan
in cuba whether it be legitimate claims
that they have to ha to get more food
and medical supplies or
to lift the [ __ ] embargo that has
been going on foreign i'm with that
i'm with all of that yeah i'm with all
of that but you're never going to hear
me praise an authoritarian regime that's
been in power for 50 60 years you know
is a total diversion and it's
exclusively centering around
what mostly predominantly white american
[ __ ] liberals
want to argue about because it's about
the sport it's not about uplifting
cuba or cuban people it's just about the
support
it's just about the sport of debate the
blood that revolves around debating and
like winning an argument with semantics
right no i i that i actually agree with
in the sense that like i'm not really
i'm not trying to be the
anti-imperialist
or the capitalist or what you know it's
just like hey
the embargo is a disaster it's failed
we got to help with elements of medical
and we can't
defend any authoritarian regime you know
what i mean it's just like it's
i it's sort of like everybody would
disagree with some ass but many people
would disagree with some aspect of that
but i think the bloodsport aspect he's
rightly identifying that is bad
slurs that are considered uh [ __ ] up
for the record
so i just want you to know that like he
is absolutely
absolutely [ __ ] just
doing engaging in this just to be like
come on dude i'm uh you know
i'm just trying to claw into that
[ __ ] relevance okay
yeah he's not he's a ridiculous person
it's an unserious person and this is an
unserious conversation
i feel like we could do we could have
dinner again and it would be fine you
know we
hassan stephen kenneth destiny been all
the second
and i had indian food and um
molina destiny bonnell ii came with us
and my uh my my uh my manager came with
us who's a friend of hassan's we it was
great
it was a good i i think that it would be
totally fine i don't think i
feel like i'd be able to negotiate at
all and everybody would be fine
destiny tells an interesting story about
islam this is a lie he said in his chat
all right anyway
let's get away from this i think we've
seen enough and here we go
today it's been my great honor
and i mean that to welcome a dear friend
back to the white house
and before i uh say anything else
chancellor merkel
i want to express to you and to uh
the people of germany my sincere
condolences and the condolences of the
american people
for the devastating loss of life and the
destruction
due to the flooding over the past 24
hours in germany and neighboring
countries
it's a tragedy and our heart goes out
our hearts go out to the families who've
lost loved ones
chancellor merkel has been here
frequently over the past 16 years
matter of fact she knows the oval office
as well as i do
but all kidding aside through
though this administration she's been
there for
four years for four presidents but i
want to take a moment to acknowledge the
historic nature of her chancellorship
first woman chancellor in german history
the first chancellor from the former
east germany
and now the second largest longest
serving chancellor since helmut cole
here's an exemplary okay
second largest germany was not a great
slip
heart to the world on behalf of the
united states thank you angela
for your career of a strong principle
leadership
and thank you for speaking out for what
is right
and for never failing to defend human
dignity
i want to thank you for your continued
support for the long standing goal
of europe whole free and
at peace you've been a stalwart champion
of the transatlantic alliance
the atlantic partnership under your
chancellorship the friendship and
cooperation
between germany united states has grown
stronger
and stronger and i'm looking forward
to celebrating more at our dinner this
evening
but today it was very much a working
visit
chancellor merkel and i covered a wide
range of issues
where germany and the united states are
working to advance a shared agenda
we discussed together with our fellow
major democracies at
the g7 germany and the united states
have responsibilities to lead with our
values as to the other
members of nato right and today
i've i've confided that
in our new washington
declaration which we've codified a
document affirming
our commitment to the democratic
principles that are heart that are at
the heart of both
of our nations and uh how we will
apply them to meet the biggest
challenges
of today and tomorrow both our nations
both our nations understand the
imperative
of proving that democracies can deliver
the needs of our people
in the second quarter of the 21st
century
we will stand up for democratic
principles and universal rights
when we see china or any other country
working to undermine
free and open societies and we are
united
united in our commitment to addressing
democratic
backsliding corruption phony populism
in union or among candidates for the eu
membership
or anywhere we find it in the world we
agree
on the importance of further integrating
the western balkans
into the european european institutions
and in our continued support for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
as well as the continued importance of
reforms
in the support of their euro-atlantic
aspirations
we stand together and will continue to
stand together to defend our eastern
flank
allies at nato against russian
aggression
and while i reread it my while i
reiterated my concerns
about nordstrom 2 sensor merkel and i
are absolutely united in our conviction
that russia must not be allowed to use
energy as a weapon
to coerce or threaten its neighbors and
today
we're launching a climate and energy
partnership
to support energy security and the
development of sustainable energy
sustainable energy technologies and
emerging
and emerging economies including in
central europe
and ukraine to unite our efforts
to up end and on our global climate
ambitions that
we have to up the ante what happened as
we talked about
when paris accord was set we thought we
had
established just how serious it was but
things have gotten much more
dire since even that date
and to unite our efforts to update to up
the antion global climate
global climate ambitions i also thank
chancellor merkel
for the dedication and the sacrifice of
german troops who have served side by
side
along with u.s forces in afghanistan for
almost
20 years and we reaffirmed our shared
commitment to continuing
to counter terrorist threats where we
find them including in the sahara
in africa and we uh
when we uh think about the future the
future we want for the world
there's no issue there's no issue said
at all
that i believe we find
anything other than the
certainty that a commitment
that between the united states and
germany
doesn't benefit whatever the problem the
concern is
we need to fight cover 19 pandemic
everywhere
to strengthen global health security for
tomorrow so we're ready for the next
pandemic
we need to make sure that the rules of
the road governing the use of emerging
technologies
advance freedom not authoritarianism and
repression
and we need to promote a sustainable and
inclusive economic recovery
that enhances the prosperity and
opportunity for all and so much more
this just this isn't just uh work of
governments
the workers work of our peoples sharing
their innovation and insights
joining together to amplify our
collective impact
so today we're launching a futures forum
between our two countries which will
bring together top experts
across business academia civil society
and more
to collaborate as we shape our shared
future
madam chancellor i know that the
partnership between germany and the
united states will continue to grow
stronger
on the foundation that you've helped to
build but on a personal note
i must tell you i'll miss seeing you at
our summits
i truly will so thank you again angela
for making the journey for our
productive meeting today
and for your friendship wow
and then
catastrophe but they've got to get her
down and the
live interpretation up
let's see if maybe on the white house
feed it's
hundreds better thousands of people uh
all of a sudden were faced with
catastrophe
uh their health there's catastrophe
literally death traps
small rivers turned into
flooded devastating
rivers and i must say that my empathy
and my heart goes out to all of those
who in this catastrophe
lost their loved ones or who are still
worrying about
the fate of people still missing and i
include
belgium luxembourg and the netherlands
who've also suffered from floodings um
the rescuers
first responders are doing their utmost
to help people
i must say that i'm very much feeling
with those who've suffered
and i know that millions of people in
germany feel the same
the minister presidents of draya miss
dreyer and
mr luschette minister presidents of
rhineland platinum and northwest
australia
respectively and also uh the ministers
who are responsible here
um i talk to them and i would like to
send
out a message to the people that we will
not leave them
alone with their suffering and that
we're trying utmost to
help them in their distress mr president
dear joe
thank you for the invitation thank you
for making it possible to
talk to you it's my first visit since
2019 and i'm
so much so happy about
the personal exchange we have seen uh
again
today that we're not only uh partners
and allies but we're
very close friends and thank you for the
very friendly exchange
you guys think that like trump biden
will refer to her as a quote
[ __ ] later today determination to
tackle the challenges of our times
to master them and i'm deeply convinced
that
simply uh committing to these values is
certainly not sufficient we are living
at a crucial moment
in time where we are facing new
challenges
and these challenges need to be
translated into practical policies so
i'm very grateful that we have this
opportunity to
work on foundations and we lay down
those foundations
in the washington declaration and also
by the way i'm going to be taking some
pretty strong lufthansa flights in the
next few weeks and i'm even going to be
in frankfurt i'm going to have one
dinner in frankfurt if you can imagine
it
it's gonna have i'm gonna have to make
it a good one right together um
what sort of solutions they think are
appropriate and i think such
structures are very important there is
a very large degree of common ground
as has come out of our talks we are
convinced both of us that
um overcoming this pandemic is only
possible if
as many people as possible are
vaccinated in our countries and many
wish to do that
we have to also support the rest of the
world with vaccines we work together
with kovacs
in kovacs and i'm very grateful to the
united states and under your leadership
dejo the u.s has committed itself very
clearly and unequivocally to
multilateralism beat
on climate be it on uh reform of the
world health organization and support
also to
wto germany and the united states
have agreed to provide vaccine doses to
poor countries we work within kovacs as
i said
we talked about the challenge of climate
change and i am
very happy that the united states are
now back again
with us in the paris climate agreement
and that for glasgow that provides us
with a totally different
uh basis in order to work among the
parties
to the treaty better in a much better
and much more efficient way for climate
um and
we see countries that are besought by um
floodings by wildfires and
by storms in an increasing manner and
that shows that there
is a dramatic increase in in such
unusual
weather phenomena and we have to contend
with this germany and the united states
um have now forged a an energy and
climate partnership
i think it's a very important message
that we're sending here
we want to build on future oriented
technologies
green hydrogen for example renewables
uh electromobility we're in competition
with others
on this planet and we would like to be
successful together and germany is very
much
looking forward to cooperating in this
respect and i support the present
in what he proposed as a
global infrastructure project which we
agreed on
on the g7 summit next year as you
probably know we will have the
chairmanship of the the presidency of
the g7 and we will bring this
um project forward we talked about
russia and ukraine and in this context
also about north stream
too we've come to different assessments
as to
what this project um entails
but let me say very clearly that little
line
we've come to different assessments that
would be
like a 24-hour trump tantrum attacking
her for her position
but the diplomacy is we've come to
different assessments i'm engaged
and continue to be engaged in the men's
process we will be
actively acting should russia
not respect this right of ukraine
that it has as a transit country so
north stream ii
is an additional project and certainly
not a project to
replace any kind of transit through
ukraine anything else
would obviously create a lot of tension
and we're also talking about
how we can actually make this
very clear together we also talked about
other priorities in our foreign policy
for example
our relationship with china we are
countries who stand up for
free democratic societies uh
stand up for those um right civic rights
for those who live in these societies so
wherever
human rights are not guaranteed we will
make our voices heard
and make clear that we don't agree with
this we are also for
territory integrity of all countries um
of the world we also talked about the
many facets of
cooperation and also of competition with
china be it in the economic area be it
on climate protection be it inc
military in the military sector and on
security
and obviously there are a lot of
challenges ahead
on the nuclear agreement with iran jcpoa
we think that everything ought to be
done in order to bring this to
a successful conclusion but i think that
is something that is also
the ball very much here is also in the
iranian camp
now over many many years we've served
together in afghanistan
we've been able to contain to a certain
degree terrorist dangers but
unfortunately we have not been able to
build a nation as we
would like it to look and
still i would hold it was a good
partnership has been a good partnership
with the united states
you know after 20 years we may not be
able to make that country what we think
we should
uh and it's probably time to get out
yeah we also talked about sail the sail
zone where terrorism is
on the rampage and obviously for us in
europe this is a great challenge
we're very and also for the countries on
the ground we're very grateful to the
united states
for their uh mission in order to contain
um and push back against these terrorist
advances
we also have drawn up a
german we've also agreed on a
german-american
dialogue between our business
communities because we have
considerable trade links and we wish to
build on this and obviously
the economy and economy ties of prime
importance
it was a very very good exchange with
close partners
i would like this to remain even after i
have left office
and i think with this visit we probably
paved the way
to make it possible uh to also create
formats
while we can exchange because the world
will continue to be a place that is full
of challenges so thank you very much for
making it possible for us
to tackle those together thank you thank
you very much
we're each going to take two questions
and i'm going to begin by oh
don't go crazy now steve portnoy and
congratulate you on your new role as a
president of the
white house correspondents association
my sympathies
no but thank you i appreciate that sir
on behalf of the press corps thank you
and we're looking forward to the day we
can have even more reporters all the way
to the back of the room so thank you
very much
i have a couple of questions for you
also a question for the chancellor um
but mr president uh with respect to
latin america and the developments there
in the last week
plus yes um what are the circumstances
under which you would
send american troops to haiti it's the
first question the second question is
um when it comes to cuba what is your
current thinking
on american sanctions toward cuba and
the embargo
today your press secretary said that uh
communism is a failed ideology
i assume that's your view i was
wondering if you could also give us your
view
on socialism this is going to be good uh
the question is good question madam the
president said that you
know the oval office as well as he does
i'm wondering if you could reflect on
your exchanges with american presidents
over the last 16 years
and particularly contrast the current
president with his most immediate
predecessors yes
yes in two minutes or less
uh nasty obviously i know why they
elected you president
um
sir you just won the election the
question relative to
uh haiti and cuba
and communism is a fail system
universally fail system and uh
i don't see socialism as a very useful
substitute but that's another story um
with regard to uh whether the
circumstance in which we would send
military troops to um haiti
we uh we're only sending american
marines to our embassy to make sure that
they are secure
and nothing is out of whack at all
the idea of sending american forces into
uh haiti is not on the agenda at this
moment
number one number two with regard to
cuba
uh cuba is a uh
unfortunately a failed state and
repressing uh
their citizens um there are
a number of things that we would
consider doing to help the people of
cuba
but they would require a different
circumstance or a guarantee
that they would not be taken advantage
of by the government for example
the ability to send remittances to
back to cuba i would not do that now
because the fact is
it's highly likely that the regime would
confiscate those remittances or big
chunks of it
with regard to the need covet on i mean
assuming they have a covert problem
on in cuba i would be prepared to
give significant amounts of vaccine if
in fact i was assured an international
organization
would administer those vaccines and do
it in a way that average citizens would
have access to those vaccines
and one of the things that
you did not ask but we're considering is
they have cut off access to the internet
um we're considering whether we have the
technological it would be great for him
to say i will also undo what trump did
with the embargo
and i think i've answered your questions
thank you not quite
not fully
to elaborate on three different points
any
german chancellor has a vested interest
to talk and that's in very much in the
vested interest of
germany to work and talk together with
any
american president we've always had um
contacts and
we you've been able to it was i think
it's very transparent
and today it was a very friendly
exchange
oh sorry i have to call uh mr kunis and
his german question
thank you very much madam chancellor mr
president um
allow me if i may to ask a question as
regards nordstrom 2 madam chancellor you
just said that you
would act actively should russia
be in breach of its commitment so for
example interrupt
gas transit through ukraine what do you
mean in concrete terms
will germany then switch off um
north stream to from the german side and
what sort of legal
grounds would you be sort of claiming mr
president uh you have fought so many
years the u.s has fought so many years
against uh north stream too
now um there will be only a few days
left until this pipeline
comes into operation um why
will you allow it to go ahead to put it
in operation or will
uh the people who operate this system
actually have to contend with sanctions
on the horizon well mr cunha says the
chancellor you know that we've
worked a lot not only germany
incidentally but the whole of the
european commission
for talking to russia and ukraine
negotiating a treaty that ensures
uh until uh in 2023
the gas contract and after that
gas deliveries must be possible as well
and that is what i've heard at least let
me be very careful here in my wording
and then um should that now go go ahead
we have a number of
instruments at our disposal which are
not necessarily
um on the german side but uh on the
european side
um for example sanctions uh and
as regards um crimea or in breach of the
minsk
treaty has shown that we have those
sanctions these instruments at our
disposal
we have possibilities to react we are in
contact with our european friends on
this
but um at the at the point in time of
which i hope
we will never have to take those
decisions you will then see what we do
my view on nordstrom 2 has been
known for some time good friends can
disagree
and but by the time i became president
it was 90 completed and
imposing sanctions did not seem to make
any sense it made more sense to work
with the chancellor on finding out
how she proceed based on whether or not
russia tried to essentially blackmail
ukraine in some way
and so the chancellor and i have asked
our teams to
look at practical measures we could take
together
[Music]
um and uh whether or not uh
europe energy security ukraine security
are actually strengthened
a weakened based on russian actions and
so this is a
we'll see we'll see
uh uh
miss leonard or bloomberg okay
okay thank you mr president
um i have two questions for you and then
some uh for
chancellor merkel as well your
administration tomorrow
is issuing a business advisory um for
hong kong
i was wondering if you can explain why
you think that is necessary
and then secondly um on your buildback
better agenda have you spoken to
senators mansion and cinema about the
3.5 trillion
dollar framework and are you confident
that they'll
be on board at that level and if they
demand that you lose some components
will you be able to keep progressives on
board
um
i wanted to ask you whether you have a
feeling that after the talk with
president biden
um he better understands
your viewpoint as regards china or
whether um
the situation is still tense whether
they're still decoupling
and secondly whether you think that the
united states has contributed um enough
to vaccinate the rest of the world or do
you think it's um only
is it appropriate for children um in the
united states being vaccinated
children below the age of 12 while
adults in other countries have no chance
to get vaccinated
that's all
i thought i said we'd take two questions
but i guess that translator would take
two questions or more from each person
called
on um
talk about the business advice man the
situation in hong kong has deteriorated
and the chinese government
is not keeping this commitment that made
how it would
deal with with hong kong and so
it is more of an advisory as to
what may happen in on hong kong it's as
simple as that and as complicated as
that
with regard to am i confident i'm
supremely confident
that everything's going to work out
perfectly uh in time
look i
understand why the press
and among others is skeptical that i can
actually get this
deal done right infrastructure and on
human infrastructure
and i've watched and listened in the
press declared my initiative dead at
least 10 times so far
i don't think is dead i think is still
alive i still have confidence we're
going to be able to get
what i proposed and what i've agreed to
in a bipartisan agreement
on infrastructure i've gotten
we've each committed i trust the members
of the
republican senators
who have made the commitments relative
to
how we should proceed and what would be
included in the package
for infrastructure and
their men and women of honor and i
expect they would keep their commitment
with regard to the further issue
of what's going on and what will confuse
the listening audience but
reconciliation that is the
mechanism by which you have to get every
single democrat to agree to proceed
on matters like what i announced today
today i don't know if you have any
children it's none of my business
whether you do but if you do you're
going to get if you're making less than
150
000 you're going to get a significant
stipend
that is a tax cut if you have a child
under the age of
of seven years old you're going to get
in your bank account today you're going
to get a payment
of one six uh
12 months divided 3 600
3700 for that child divided by 12 every
month
right just like a social security check
it's expected to reduce
child poverty by over 40 percent
and it could be a significant
significant game changer
we have mechanisms to pay for both these
mechanisms
and uh there may be some mechanisms to
pay for mechanisms
is good who what mechanism is used to
pay
for each of these items both the
infrastructure package and the human
infrastructure package
but i believe we will get it done
thank you
we talked about china and um there is
um a lot of common understanding that
china in many areas is our competitor
that trade with china needs to rest in
the assumption that we have a level
playing field so that we
all well play by the same rules uh have
the same standards that incidentally was
also uh the driving force be behind the
eu
china agreement on trade that they uh
abide by the core labor norms of ilo
and we are convinced of uh
ours needing to be technological leaders
for our countries
our two countries in both in many many
areas obviously
it's legitimate for china wishing to do
this as well but for example we will
cooperate in many
uh technological state-of-the-art
technologies for example chips i think
the act that
the president launched is fundamental
in this respect and crucial and we
want to trade together at a time of
digitalization where
security issues uh loom very large on
our agendas we ought to have an exchange
on this we ought to talk about this we
ought to
talk about uh norms standards that
govern the internet uh whether we can
agree on common norms i think
particularly as regards the relationship
of us with china we ought to coordinate
our efforts we do that in the european
union
and we should do it uh with the united
states and then there are interests
obviously sometimes divergent
interests but sometimes common interests
but we also have obviously areas where
american companies compete with
european companies and we have to accept
that but i think
basically uh the rules as to how we deal
with
china or to rest and do rest on
um our shared values um and and i think
um on the pandemic we are obviously of
the opinion that the pandemic we can
only master the
pandemic if uh each and everyone is
vaccinated
we are trying to boost production we are
trying also to get as many people in our
country vaccinated as possible
which obviously um opens us up to
criticism of those countries who as yet
have not had the chance
which is why we invested a lot of money
in coax which is why we encourage our
companies
to increase their production of vaccines
and in africa we are trying to help
africans to
upskill people so that they too can have
their own production sites we're going
to do this
but de facto there is an imbalance i
agree
uh but we're overcoming we're putting
our all into that and also together
in overcoming that imbalance um i'm
sorry
i call on ms schoebler from the tiger
speaker um
newspaper spiegel thank you one for each
of you
mr president my question my first
question
touches an issue that worries a lot of
people
in the us and in germany can you explain
to us
why there still is a travel ban for
people coming from germany
or other states of the european union
while people from turkey where the
number of new cases
are seven times as high perfect
questions
have repeatedly said that you're
following scientific data
what is the main argument for not
lifting beautiful
for the schengen region and chancellor
merkel
you talked to the business companies
here
you heard their concerns you heard their
headaches
some have threatened that they're going
to shift business away from the united
states
what was your main argument uh to work
for
a lifting of the travel ban and have you
had success with this
we brought in the head of our
arkova team because the chancellor
brought that subject up
it's in the process of seeing how soon
we can lift the band it's in process now
and i'll be able to answer that question
to you within the next several days
what is likely to happen i'm waiting to
hear from
our folks in our our cova team
as to when that should be done
kind of a cop-out but okay cancer did
raise it
i did raise the issue yes um
and got the same answer that the
president gave you just now
the cover team is uh evaluating the
matter
we had an exchange on uh in both areas
the delta variant uh actually uh being
on the increase that is
again a new challenge to both of us and
obviously before such a decision
one has to reflect and it has to be a
sustainable decision
it is certainly not sensible to uh have
to take it back after only a few
days so i'm have every confidence in the
american covert team
having been here many times we don't
leave right now we're going to miss
dinner
chancellor and i have a dinner with some
a number of folks and
very shortly so thank you for your
attention and thank you for your
for your nice early dinner huh thank you
all right there it is uh president joe
biden and
german chancellor angela merkel for
people asking will i be seeking out
sausages when i go to frankfurt in a few
weeks
no they're mostly pork and i haven't
eaten pork in a decade
but i will seek out the best chicken
schnitzel someone recommended to me a
place in frankfurt called main diner
i have no idea whether that's the best
chicken schnitzel
but i will take recommendations thank
you very much everybody
we will see you all uh very very soon
that's absolutely clear
[Laughter]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host an executive producer
of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is a beta male 1
david patman he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is a baby